john jeff you gentlemen are entering the
final round of this three-round
competition now we're sending you back
to your home forge to recreate this
iconic weapon from history
that weapon is
the messer
and by knife
it gonna be a challenge good luck blade
smiths we will see you in four days
so i'm back at my home forge and i'm
really excited about that but i get uh
four days to make two blades and
that's insane
i don't have time to do one at a time
this is gonna be two irons in the fire
and swapping them in and out
you know i'd much rather be able to
concentrate on one thing but uh
this is forged in fire baby got the
blades all forged out one of the
parameters for the sword is that it has
to have a fuller putting these fullers
in is probably the most nerve-wracking
part and get them too deep you can get
them off centered screwing these fullers
up could mean day one is starting over
tomorrow
yes sir that works
i'm finally home i'm ready to roll shake
it once check it twice check it 10 times
today i want to start with my buy knife
so i know how much time i have to work
with to make that long message blade's
got to be between here
and here this homie don't mess up his
links
i've managed to forge out the buy knife
things are going a lot quicker than i
ever expected they would be i'm liking
it
so i'm going to start attacking the long
master i've never done anything quite
that size come here you big monster it's
scaring the bejeebers out of me still
got my fingers crossed that i've got the
length i want
i'm ready to quench two quenches twice
to work
twice the worry
yes sir the messer sword is up to
temperature and it's time to quench
here comes the real test please be hard
yes
hell yes
this is my baby now
so let me take care of it
today i need to get the messer heat
treated if it cracks i don't know that
i'm going to have enough time to make
another one
last 18 hours of busting my butt comes
up to this
right now the only plan b i can think of
is cry
it's called the sire relief
this song's gonna straight
no that worked great
starting day four and i'm a lot more
tired than i was day one i'm getting the
parts together for the messer sword i'm
doing the final fit and grind on them
dual wield the thing just makes you feel
like a badass when you're holding it i
mean i have to chop something with it so
to test my messer sword i do an antler
chop antler is some tough stuff and
if it survives it it should survive
anything uh hopefully it doesn't break
i'm getting what i want i'm still gonna
try to get it a little sharper for
slicing but
for chopping man that's freaking awesome
all right bladesmiths this is the pig
carcass slice and dice
i will take your weapon and deliver
killing blows on this big carcass
john your first you ready for this let's
make some bacon bud
this is not an easy test to pass this is
where i find out did i make a sword or a
couple pieces of scrap metal
oh yeah
yes
all right john your messer is sharp
it's a little bit forward heavy but the
weight
lends itself to chop the pig in half now
your by knife razor sharp those cuts
alone were cutting deeply with every
move and overall sir it will kill oh yes
all right jeff your turn you ready yes
sir let's do this
all right jeff your messer
beautiful balance it's not forward heavy
it actually is something i can wield
forward same balance on the recovery
when i'm pulling back to cut now your by
knife the edge is razor sharp with every
cut and stab that it does overalls are
your weapons
they will kill thanks sir
right gentlemen now to test the strength
and durability of your blades i'll be
chopping into our log here
now remember this is not about what your
messers are going to do that log or what
that log might do to your messers and
then i'm going to take your by knives
and we're gonna do a tip test by driving
that tip your blade into that log all
right john you're up you ready do your
worst okay
all right john well let's start with
your messenger your edge is still sharp
blade's still straight true your blade's
got a lot of weight to it your handle
is a little confusing when you're
swinging this having that bead right
there my hand kind of wants to go all
the way up to the guard and having this
the well further back sort of pushes my
hand a little bit back behind where i'd
like it to be as far as your by knife
goes not a mark on it really well done
thank you sir all right jeff
your turn you ready yes sir okay
all right let's start with your messer
what i really like about this blade
is the way you balanced it puts all that
weight right back in my hand where i
want it your knife
it's a really pretty piece it's very
comfortable in the hand but um
just a little brittle on the tip
but they are both beautiful pieces
nicely done thanks sir
all right bladesmiths the rope slice
surprise
now unlike the strength this is all
about what your edge will do to
different materials we have out here
john you're up first you ready for this
please do sir do this
all right john we're in the first cup
with your buy knife it's a light knife
didn't cut all the way through it's
starting to unravel and of course your
messer finish that off
on these tubes
it's cut cleanly all the way through
your weapon sir a little cup
thank you
all right jeff it's your turn you ready
sir yes sir
all right jeff first up your buy knife
despite the fact that just the tip broke
off
the edge is razor sharp with one cut it
cut cleanly through the rope your messer
once again the balance just feels so
good in the hand it's such an easy
weapon to wield and slice
overall sir your weapons
will cut
thank you sir they're going to be
judging both of these weapons not just
one the knife broke but the sword
performed above and beyond
it's anybody's game i think
blade smith's the judge's deliberation
is complete
they've made their final decision
our new fortune fire champion is
jeff congratulations you're the new
foreign fire champion john unfortunately
your blades did not make the cut
john while jeff's by knives tip broke on
the strength test it outperformed yours
on the sharpness test the combination of
the balance the forward weight and your
handle design well that's the reason
we're sending it home
john please surrender your blades
somebody has to win and i wish it could
have been me
but i honestly feel the judges made the
right decision jeff's messer was a work
of art and he deserved to win what i
loved about this is that
it stretched me far beyond what i
thought i could do
and i did it
jeff congratulations you're the new
forrester fire chairman and that's the
title that comes with a check for ten
thousand dollars how do you feel right
now
uh
validated sir please present your blades
to the judges
i'm happy um i can't even describe my
emotions right now ford's and fire
champion baby bringing it back to
kentucky hell yeah
yes
you